[Musique]
boris johnson beaux jours pour les
tabloïds britanniques ou simplement
boris c'est un politicien charismatique
controversé qui est aussi très facile à
caricaturer
[Musique]
c'est également un journaliste ça c'est
important de le savoir parce que c'est
comme ça que boris johnson s'est fait
connaître
c'est comme ça aussi qu'il est devenu
l'un des politiciens les plus influents
du royaume uni sa carrière a mal
commencé on pourrait dire il a été
renvoyé de son premier emploi de
journaliste pour avoir inventé une
citation il s'est retrouvé du travail
à bruxelles la bassée texte exagérait
souvent les torts les travers de l'union
européenne
ce sont quand même des textes qui ont
été très populaires et qui ont beaucoup
inspiré le courant eurosceptiques
c'est aussi un politicien qui n'hésitent
pas à changer d'avis que ce soit au
sujet de l'élection de donald trump de
l'entrée possible de la turquie dans
l'union européenne au sujet du brésil
comme journaliste il a écrit deux
chroniques une pour chacun une pour
chaque position avant d'en publier une
seule celle dans laquelle il se disait
en faveur de quitter l'union européenne
lui parle de ces deux chroniques
aujourd'hui comme d'un exercice de style
ses détracteurs par contre il voit
surtout le signe d'un opportunisme
politique
d'ailleurs la question des ambitions de
boris johnson s'est souvent présenté les
souvent revenue sur le tapis au cours de
sa carrière
cox 2010 paul beeston
bien sûr boris johnson
il a été l'une des voix les plus
influentes lors de la campagne pour le
breakbeat après le référendum il a fait
beaucoup pour miner la crédibilité et
l'autorité de terry âmes et la première
ministre
et puis il n'a jamais cessé de militer
pour un divorce le plus net possible d'
avec l'union européenne
c'est un politicien qu'on dit très près
du peuple qui se met parfois les pieds
dans les plats avec des déclarations
inappropriées par exemple avec des
gestes trop brusques ou encore avec des
insultes lancées aux femmes ou aux
musulmans qui donne en tout beaucoup de
raisons aux britanniques pour craindre
son arrivée éventuelle autant dans 18
mai mais attention
boris johnson demeure quand même un
politicien qui est très populaire au
royaume uni entre autres à cause de sa
personnalité et aussi à cause de ses
travers et puis on en parle comme d'un
homme du politicien qui peut être le
mieux placé pour redorer le lustre du
parti conservateur
un parti qui est très impopulaire ces
temps ci au royaume uni ça c'est un
argument qui est très important parce
que ceux qui vont choisir le prochain
premier ministre
ce sont pas les britanniques mais ce
sont les membres du parti conservateur
des gens qui ont maintenant un mois pour
choisir entre boris johnson et son rival
jeremy craintes
[Applaudissements]